welcome to this video bop ba-bop ba-bop
ball who is that no name ok I'm going
with a classical opening here maybe the
Queens gambit declined good or what
Queens gambit declined the most
dependable of Defense's oops oops nope
remove here 22 that is an interesting
move and the whole line with Bishop
length of six it's actually quite
interesting and I always forget to study
it so okay I'm going with 96 I think
that is a line intending to take and
play me five oops really that is sharp
okay it's not ideal to do it he had give
him that capture in one move but anyway
let's not be too sophisticated him we
are taking is probably leading nowhere
so d5 astounding that we are probably RT
five I don't think any other move would
impose any serious problem I wonder no
it's doing this yeah well this this is
some not very sharp I guess let's just
take a check
yeah that's some way to trade some stuff
94 no it's not doing this okay yeah
strange um have a strange concept with
them the bishop on c4 there I mean think
the King position is the real deal the
real problem um ok now I can take and
play night before at least or just look
to the aid
okay let's put the rook on the eight
yeah great position yeah my man just
have play against that pawn on d4 his
King as a bit shaky I cannot move it to
the side ok I've got 97 or I don't I
mean I don't need to move the night
necessarily but 97 I mean how i see
covering that porn the d5 pawn no that's
okay I win that big Center porn it's a
good way to start things here I'm also
threatening a rope t5 of c-5 that's very
inconvenient so
it was a very strange way to play it
with 95 and so on d5 looked very normal
and then I'm not really sure that that
um was any anything great for me I don't
think so actually some doubts there
anyway he's playing to play the Queen a
five if he takes on a seven night before
really should be good the main thread on
c2 okay where are you going with this
let's start with this move Quincy five
rook c8 and after we'll move night
before
right before here
you I just wonder if there's anything
even better let's go down rook takes is
made on c2 Queen d8 if it takes
everything with the Queen there I always
have night a 2 at the end stuff like
that okay so i can do this here 93 for
an exchange or is there anything better
well it's been chess change come on it's
a cash cash in time like Rosanna don't
need to check me to every every time
yeah it was a very strange way of
playing the same I think g5 it's only
move and it makes perfect tense tempo on
the noise I probably go here and then
something like this intending d6 I was
thinking night f5 maybe 496 it's an
interesting position that's not a dull
equal position as it sometimes happens
and some Queens gambit the Queens gambit
declines that's a sharp position due to
the king yeah after that I'm just I'm
just comfortable check took there yeah i
was thinking night cheeks maybe this
this i was thinking taking on f2 looks
risky so after this i can do with this
and go see 5 that looks a bit more
promising I like my position are
probably a bit better but I still
surprised at this move Bishop f5 or g4
they're both good rock g8
just a matter of choosing one way to
tend it on Tim he has no alternative to
taking everything oops taking everything
and playing them makes change down and
it's not just the exchange it's still
that his King is totally boxed and it
will be probably am yeah we won't
survive that next couple of moves okay
well thanks for watching